[Music]
brian's in omaha nebraska hey brian
welcome to the ramsay show what's up
hey dave how's it going better than we
deserve how can we help
uh yeah um so my question is well i
guess there should be a little bit of
backstory um
me my girlfriend and my six month old we
moved out of the apartment that we were
staying at um
they were raising the rent on us and
then uh we just our her parents decided
to
uh let us stay at their house until we
were able to
save enough money to either buy a house
or rent another another house
or apartment and um basically
i feel kind of i feel kind of horrible
for doing that i don't feel like
i don't feel like as
good as i should because i know saving
up is what we need to do and i know i
have some debt to pay off so i want to
use the opportunity to to actually save
and and pay off as much debt as possible
before um the six months to a year is up
that they had allowed us to stay
um but
i mean is it i guess one of my questions
is is that is that the right thing that
i did or should i have just kind of
manned up and try to pay
the extra money that they were charging
or and then also um i mean what's the
next step here because i know paying the
debt off is a big one but
it just doesn't feel like i can do it in
the amount of time that i'm being given
so let me jump in
number one
paying an accelerated rent rake has
nothing to do with manhood
uncouple those number two why do you
feel awful you said you feel awful
um i've always been that type of person
to never accept
help
so okay
you feel like you feel like a charity
case you feel like you're failing your
wife and your kid
yeah
okay how old are you
uh 26. what do you do for a living
i'm a mechanic for a dealership cool
what do you make
um
i haven't completed a full year um so i
know i get paid about 2 800 a month i
think over a year
can be 40 45 thousand yeah sounds right
and uh after you've completed your year
does your income go up
um i am not entirely sure about that i
know after like six months they did it
did come up pretty good
um
but uh after a year i believe
it should i just don't know how are you
asi
uh asc no um i have a couple ases done
but not completely certified um i guess
that counts and then the dealership that
i work for they have their own training
that they want to come
uh she doesn't um we haven't been able
to afford like daycare still she's a she
stays at home
well if she made 100 000 a year you
could afford it what did she
do well she doesn't work i know why
should she have a degree
i know she's in school right now um like
i said i'm 26 and but she's 20 and she's
going for uh
our sociology
so brian i
i'll just take a page out of my own my
own story
um
i
took on the burden of the student loan
debt
between me and my wife i had about six
figures we did together
um and ultimately we sold our house and
i moved us at my insistence um
and she went along with it into a
residence hall a dorm
with a two-year-old
and i felt like a loser
and i felt like a failure
and
i looked at the math
and i came to terms with the fact that
the single most quote-unquote manly
thing i could do would be to
have a really hard year
an uncomfortable 18 months
and in that 18 months we didn't spend
anything
and we paid off six figures in a very
short amount of time we took i took
extra jobs i worked like crazy
and in retrospect i can't think of a
better thing i did to stop the madness
stop the sunk cost stop dumping money
into my pride and ego and to stop and
say i need help
and the help came through
this this area right and then we got
after got to work and then put a period
at the end of that sentence and moved on
asking should you have moved is you've
already moved so asking yourself that
question's a a waste of energy asking
yourself should you move again maybe
that may be another question to ask
but going back and saying and and
debating that decision you've already
made it man let that roll off don't
carry that sucker around with you
how much debt do you have
um i have about
6 000 in credit cards
500 in school loans
17 in
and car payments and then
um
who has the 17 000 car you or your wife
i do um it's the only reliable car we
have but right now i know that
it's got some hail damage that is
getting repaired as soon as that gets
repaired i know i'm gonna try and get
rid of it as soon as possible yeah good
and get you a hoopty and get yourself
out of debt it's a good time to be
selling a used car okay um
here's the thing
um i don't know how mature
emotionally your 20 year old wife is but
she needs to make some income
even if it's working from home
even if it's selling stuff on ebay she
needs to get off her butt
and uh you need to get off your butt and
figure out what your income is and how
you can go make more you don't even know
what you make for sure and you don't
know what your uh promotion process is
you need to go get some money both of
you and get this mess cleaned up and get
your autonomy back and get your
sustainability back and when you get
autonomous again on your own on your own
two feet and both of you have a plan
you're gonna be making some money and
you're gonna be winning again but right
now you're just wandering living in your
mama's basement her mama's basement